What's the proper level of analysis
because as I mentioned this to begin with,
it's very difficult to
formulate the question.
The original question is
what led to the issue.
I would say their request to the question
of human motivation for evil except
perhaps the opposite question,
which is human motivation for good,
you will also historically positive it's
opposite or the dark because of light
or the evil you are of
the opposite of that.
There's no way around them.
So it's the same question and that would
be the question I suppose suppose of
ethical behavior morale or something
like that and the question,
the question of its nature,
the nature of reality in the world.
It's a deep question.
You'd say deepest,
deepest question and it
requires formulation at the
deepest possible level of
analysis and it's a mystery that requires
formulation at the deepest possible
level of analysis.
And so you accepted to
history and you accepted.
It's the deepest level
analysis and yourself,
where do you go find an actual to request
it that's mysterious at the deepest
possible level of analysis and answer
that at least the part as you go or you
don't go where you don't know.
You go to that place that you don't know.
There's actually a technical,
it's a technical issue.
So one of the things that current,
and I think this is well supported by
the relevant neuropsychological and
neuropsychiatric literature,
is that your dreams and your fantasies
containing information that you don't yet
know.
Now that's not an easy thing to
understand because you might take,
let's say you have a dream and you
figure out what the dream means.
There's a mystery,
which is,
well,
if you didn't know what the three,
then how the hell did you dream,
right?
I mean because you drive,
you don't understand it.
So how does that work?
Because how can you think of
something that you don't understand?
Part of the answers that
you're not exactly a unity.
There's parts of you that know things
that other parts of you don't know.
And there's parts of you that know
things in ways that the part of you that
talks can't understand and there's
things that you act out that are too
complicated for you to
represent her to articulate.
And so there's lots of
things about you that were,
that you don't understand
that or lesson foreman,
you know what?
You don't know how you breathe,
you don't know your heart works,
how your heart and so you don't
have voluntary control over that.
So it's not surprising in
some sense that you're,
your mind could produce contents
that transcends your articulate.
No UMES idea was that,
that's what dreams did.
What dreams were doing
essentially was you a world view.
And that world is only partial obviously,
because what the hell,
you know,
so you know,
you're,
you're limited in your knowledge
and you're articulate and your,
and your logical it an integrated,
articulate knowledges,
limited domain,
and there's lots of things that
exist outside that made it goes,
it takes,
you don't understand or
errors that you've made.
And you also have to cope with them.
You have to start provisionally
understanding them because
not only do you have
to understand what you understand,
you have to come to understand
what you don't yet understand.
Right?
And that's how you learn and it's August.
How that happens at UMES idea was that
this is an elaboration is I think to some
degree while you learn in part by acting
and then you in part by representing
that APP and you learn by
analyzing this representation.
And I would say yoga is not particular,
well,
regardless,
in most cases,
by modern,
more biologically oriented
psychologists and medical practitioners.
But that's generally because they don't
understand what the hell he was talking
about.
So the reason is there's
good no psychiatric evidence,
neuropsychological epis that that's
actually how the brain functions.
So there is a neuropsychologist
and Goldberg who was a student,
he took another girl would call it
just made Alexander Luria is a Russian,
probably the greatest school
psychologist of the 20th century.
He basically laid the groundwork,
the modern understanding of the way
the brain functions in his students
discovered extraordinarily
fundamental neurophysiological facts.
Brady's and heavy hitter.
I guess student Kokona Goldberg was
very interested in why we have two
hemispheres.
It's not wrong.
We have two brains and there is evidence.
There was surgery that was government,
not so much anymore but years ago
when people had intractable epilepsy.
That cost to cut two hemispheres,
Corpus Callosum,
which is the fat tissue that
copper hemispheres and collective
consciousness
in you in your feet,
you have to consciousness is somewhat
separate that you communicate,
but at each house had various functions
and what that implies is if you need to
look at the world in two ways and that
implies maybe that the world is some
sense fundamentally divisible into two
because otherwise why would you involve
the brain?
Then we'd look at it in two ways.
Since you evolve to active live hitting
the world and it's not just you because
animals have two hemispheres as well.
It's very fun and what Goldberg suggested
was that your left hemisphere was
specialized for operation in places that
you understand your right hemisphere
was specialized for operation and
places that you don't understand.
I need to think about that.
If you want to think about it from
a more biological perspective,
you could say that you have one system,
say psychological system that
orients you explored territory,
which is where we're things are familiar
and where you can predict what's going
to happen,
where what you want to happen is happening
because that's the best definition of
being comfortable,
right?
You know,
you know where you are when you act and
what you want to have happen happens.
That's a place that's home that's
explored territory and what an unexplored
territory is.
The space beyond accounting higher,
let's say the darkness
of the 19 the jungle,
but also that place where the things that
you didn't know what to expect or what
happened and he's the best bring.
So that's what the world is composed of,
the substance of the world of experience.
It's all those things that you want to
have happen that you're familiar with and
all those things that
go bump in the night.
All those things that rise up out
of the unknown to disrupt your,
the best laid plans of mice,
let's say.
And so you do have these
two separate groups,
logical systems in the way.
And so that was all fine,
but ultimately Goldberg quite nicely and,
uh,
it's been verified by their
own neuropsychiatric status.